because
all right well Mr President it's good to
be here with you and your colleagues
thanks for making the trip
to uh Japan
and uh you're the brave people Ukraine
lived by you and your colleagues here
just to Marvel to the rest of the world
I don't think
even three years ago anybody would have
thought it could be anything like this
that's why the United States continues
to do all we can to strengthen Ukraine's
ability to defend itself
including launching some new joint
efforts with our partners to train
Ukrainian pilots on the fourth
generation fighter aircraft like the
F-16
and this week the G7 also posed hundreds
of new sanctions and Export controls
against Russia's assets
to ensure that we keep pressure on food
in the hole his backers accountable for
this war either sanctioning them as well
today I'm announcing the next trance of
U.S security assistance Ukraine
a package that includes more ammunition
artillery armored vehicles to bolster
Ukraine's Battlefield abilities
and the United States continues to help
Ukraine respond
recover and rebuild
and we're also supporting your pursuit
to adjust peace just one aspect of
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
Integrity has to be non-negotiable it
just has to happen
so Mr President what the people in
Ukraine are defending what you've
achieved is a matter for the entire
world to observe and they're in awe of
what you've done so far really and truly
it's incredible
together with the entire G7
we have Ukraine's back and I promise
we're not going anywhere
so
thank you for being here
thank you very much Mr President I trust
of all thank you for your help's
leadership for your support and really
for this new package that's great thank
you very much from all our people and
I'm so happy that you know we have so
strong relations with our people and our
people during this all these challenges
they go shoulder to shoulder I'm very
thankful to American people to to you
your team congress bipartisan support
and I'm happy that meeting our teams
there are strong relations so we're very
thankful
that is a new package
I really didn't know the details but I
know that you gave us very big package
during this year as more than 37 billion
my appreciations
you know my private meeting with
president zielinski after the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots in fourth generation
fighter aircraft including f-16s to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself we provided the
last year all that they needed to deal
with what they were dealing with at the
moment and that's when now we're moving
in the direction of putting them in a
position to be able to be defend
themselves in ways beyond what they've
had to deal with so far I have a flat
Assurance from the from zelinski that
they will not they will not use it to go
on and move into Russian Geographic
territory
but wherever Russian troops are within
Ukraine and the area they would be able
to do that Canada is already engaged in
a broad range of training exercises with
the Ukrainian military and we're always
looking for two more to to do more and
we're certainly not opposed to helping
in all sorts of different ways in
training uh training Ukrainian uh
Ukrainian soldiers and potentially
Pilots